70 years ago more than 100 young Cubans
attacked this military base in the
eastern city of Santiago de Cuba hoping
to ignite an uprising against the
government of Valencia Batista the
attack was botched and the fighters were
rounded up some imprisoned others
executed many tortured
Jose Albert de Leon was just a teenager
but it left an impression
brutality with which the dictatorship
reacted to the attacks made many young
people aware of what the Batista
dictatorship represented Leon went on to
join Fidel Castro's self-proclaimed
Rebel Army in the late 50s
and rolled into Havana with Castro in
the January 1959 Revolution before
becoming his chauffeur and a bodyguard
he says It's upsetting to see Cubans
struggling but that he doesn't regret
his decision
I'm 87 now I've still got a few years
left and I can still put my finger on
the trigger to defend any just cause
ashes are buried here in Santiago and
the 26th of July National Rebellion day
Remains the most important date on the
political calendar
but residents of Santiago have paid a
high price people here in Cuba's Second
City are harder hit by the country's
economic crisis than those in the
capital several people I spoke to today
told me they haven't received cooking
oil rations for three months in such
hard times do people think that the
attack on the monkada barracks and the
revolution it sparked was worth it
opinions are divided
I was born in the 1960s and with the
Triumph of the Revolution I became a
professional my family didn't have to
pay a penny so for me it was worth it we
are suffering a lot today but it was
worth it this young teacher thinks it's
wrong to celebrate when there are so
many shortages
what's the point of Independence and
Revolution if there's hunger scarcity of
goods and if public health is getting
worse I'm a teacher and we're teaching
without resources it's really hard to
raise a child I'm not
counter-revolutionary but I'm not blind
either
in this city long considered the
birthplace of the Revolution prolonged
hardship is cutting into government
support Ed Augustine Al Jazeera Santiago
La Cuba